[Musique]
allez tout de suite les résultats sport
du week-end avec michael et demi d'euros
bonsoir journalistes aux sports de la
rédaction du football pour commencer
avec le championnat de régionale 2
interdit y vino a pour terminer l'année
2019 quoi de mieux trappe recevait
l'équipe 2 de versailles est l'occasion
de la 10e journée de régionale 2 après
une fin de match à suspense les
trappistes arrache finalement le match
nul score final un but partout on écoute
les réactions on est rentré en deux à
mi-temps avec un visage un peu plus
conquérant et on avait à coeur de le
ramener au minimum ce point du match nul
c'est un match engagé contre
non
pour les deux équipes qui jouent le
maintien savait que ça allait être un
combat assez difficile qui plus est avec
un terrain très compliqué donc le
résultat nul me semble logique
après ce résultat trap est toujours sous
la menace d'une relégation en fin de
saison les trappistes pointe à la 10e
place sur 12 équipes engagées
mais l'équipe termine l'année sur une
note positive depuis le retour sur le
banc d'hisham et redit trappe reste sur
une série de deux victoires et deux nuls
en quatre matches et le championnat
reprendra le 2 janvier le 19 janvier
pendant le championnat de régionale 2
avec un match face à aux oies on parle
maintenant handball lors du bilan pour
montigny-le-bretonneux sur cette
première partie de saison
l'heure du bilan jouer ce week-end le
dernier match de l'année du côté de
montigny-le-bretonneux
les féminines ont fait ont fait plaisir
à leurs supporters présents alors
offrant une belle victoire contre les
premières du classement tôt le carantec
le score 35 à 28 cette victoire permet à
l'équipe de terminer troisième du
classement avant noël on écoute le
président il dresse son bilan de cette
première partie de saison on aurait pu
faire mieux on aurait pu tout gagné on
aurait pu tout gagner mais on a eu
également de travers on sait on a
rencontré l'équipe
d'ici paris de réserve ou en fait
l'équipe pro ne jouait pas et avec des
descentes de joueuse professionnelle qui
nous ont pas fait que du bien c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
montigny le bretonneux reprendra le 5
janvier prochain contre marcel verne
merci michael pour ces résultats et on
en retrouvera d'autres encore dans votre
émission le cetud sport dans un instant
sur tv 78 et vous dresserez aussi voilà
c'est la dernière émission de cette
année 2010 9,1 bilan sportif des club
yvelinois
ce sera tout à l'heure sur tv 78